Excited, Pete?
About what?
Aboput the fact that you
are going to be...
...uno de los hombres más
importantes del pais esta noche.
- ¿Piensas eso?
After 25 years ruling
the underworld...
...Benny Costain, el hombre más
poderoso y temido del pais,...
...será procesado gracias
a Pete Tonelli.
¿Sabe lo que hace Costain...
...a los que intentan delatarle?
Después de su testimonio...
...no estará aquí
para hacer nada, Pete.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm gonna be on the stand.
Why, sure you are, Pete.
You're gonna get on the stand.
And we'll see to it that nothing
happens to you after you do.
We sure will.
Oh, now, look, kid, it isn't so bad.
See if you can't think of this joint...
...as a sort of a training ground
for future life.
Of course, training for what
beats me.
But I've never been in prison before.
Half the time, I don't know
what they're saying.
Because I don't know,
I do something wrong.
- Then they yell at me like I'm stupid.
- Okay, kid, so now you can relax.
You finally got your first break
since they dragged you in.
- Break?
- Certainly, they turned you over to me.
I happen to know more about this joint
than those grafters that built it.
Yeah, but I don't.
Okay, so you don't.
So I'm gonna tell you.
Certain things in the beginning is
more important to know than others.
And other things is
even more important than that.
And one of the most important things
in this place...
...is, don't volunteer for nothing.
- Don't volunteer?
- Now, remember that.
When they come, wagging their tails
and trying to act warm and friendly...
...about some extra work that's gotta
be done, you don't do nothing.
You just sit there,
like a hunk of wet wash.
And don't volunteer.
Why not?
Why should you help the jerks out...
...that's keeping you here,
for one thing?
And don't ever do one bit more than
just exactly what you're told to do.
But how do you get around them?
Okay. Supposing they come to me,
and they say:
"Conley, on this floor,
there's a spot."
Do I go ahead and wet-mop
from here to extremity?
Not you.
Not on your life, I don't.
And I don't go over that floor...
...except just where they point out
it's spotty exactly.
And what do we usually say
about that?
You usually say, "Don't you have
no brains, Conley?
Don't you know we meant
to clean the whole filthy floor?"
That always gives Conley
a chance to say...
"If I had any brains,
what would I be doing in this trap?"
Come on, you're wanted
in the warden's office.
The warden's office?
For what? It's just about time
for the dinner to gong.
Now, don't show off, Conley.
Come on.
Like poor, dumb sheep, we're
moved from barn to stall...
...and nobody tells us why.
It's inhuman.
Don't volunteer for nothing.
This way.
When we're thrown off schedule...
...you can't blame our stomachs
for growling a little.
Hello, Conley.
As I understand it, Conley will
remain in our custody even though...
...you'll take her outside the prison?
- That's right.
- Get her into her street clothes.
- Yes, ma'am.
Anything wrong?
If there was,
I'd be the last one to be told.
That will do, Conley.
I don't suppose it'd do any good if I
ask if my civil rights is being violated.
I have a court order to give you
to the federal authorities.
In an unfed condition?
We won't be long, lieutenant.
This time, the inmate's stomach
is not to be blamed.
Four years of too many potatoes,
Conley.
Potatoes? I thought those were
plastic cotton balls they were testing.
Look out, will you?
Would you mind telling me
what this is all...?
Nobody talks to me.
Well, aren't we the real life-size
Boston Blackies.
Why? Why?
Help yourself.
Thanks.
Hey, look at them new styles!
I guess maybe these old rags of mine
must look like Easter parade in 1902.
Sister, I wouldn't know styles
if you shoved them down my throat.
You're sure of that, huh?
Why? Because you had so many
of them shoved down your throat?
Why is it nobody ever thought
of building a nice, big statue...
...to the first cop who ever called
a girl "sister"?
Because if he hadn't come along...
...the police would sure put on
their bare faces for small talk.
What's it with a cop?
Always gotta call you "sister."
You like "mother" better?
Maybe I'd like my own name
for a change.
- Maybe you would.
- Yeah, try it for size.
Oh, look! Polka dots!
Look at that dress in the window!
I hope you don't object to a person
looking out their own window.
You'll know right away
if I object to anything.
What'll you do, light up?
Would the world collapse
if somebody told me something?
Somebody will.
Clayton.
- Whole floor cleared?
- Yes, sir.
- How about the roof?
- The men are already up there.
What are we gonna have, a party?
What kind of prisoners
do you keep here?
Willoughby, get her settled.
I'll be back in a minute.
You didn't tell her anything?
What about the trip here?
You sure you weren't followed?
I'm sure I was. I lost them.
- You're positive?
- Please.
All right.
What's she like, Vince?
Just like the rest that come
through the lineup.
Smart-talking, brassy,
third-class citizen.
And she's our last chance.
If she doesn't come through,
we'll be thrown out of court Monday...
...and there goes two years' work.
Then she ought to be in the city jail,
where Costain can't knock her off.
Let's do it my way.
- What's so interesting?
- People.
And cars.
But mostly people who can go
anyplace they wanna go.
Haven't seen anybody like that
for four years.
- Who's that?
- My daughter.
- Are you married?
- I was.
He died in France,
in the Normandy landings.
None of us never knew that.
It must scare you to have a daughter
with a job like yours...
...that always points out
what can happen to a girl.
And she's pretty.
Pretty lucky kid to have a mother
like you that's so crazy about her.
Of course, I am crazy about her,
but how did you know?
You should've seen your look
when I said she was pretty.
Willoughby, send her in here.
I guess they want you in there now.
For what?
I don't know any more than you do,
but you'd better go.
You don't, huh?
We arrived at the place
where you'll explain...
...this dragging of a person
from here to there?
Yes, we've finally arrived
at that place, Miss Conley.
Would you please sit down?
My name is Lloyd Hallett.
I'm an attorney for the government.
You mean I'm up
for some kind of tax rap?
No, you're not up for any kind
of raps, so you can just relax.
Would you care for a cigarette?
One for later, after dinner.
Certainly.
We thought you could be helpful
by giving us some information...
...about a case that I'm prosecuting.
Case? What I know about cases,
you can put on the head of a pin.
- Perhaps I can be a bit more explicit.
- You do that.
You used to go around with a man
named Pete Tonelli, didn't you?
Go around? You mean, like
merry-go-rounds and revolving doors?
I mean, you used to be
a friend of Tonelli's.
- Friends, perhaps, but nothing more.
- Miss Conley...
...there's no danger of implicating
yourself by answers you might give.
I'd just like it made clear if Pete's done
anything, he can do his own hanging.
- Well, that point is now on the record.
- That's good.
You took a trip one time with Pete,
didn't you?
It was on a yacht.
And I believe you went
to the West Indies.
- Yacht?
- Yeah, those long, white things.
I know what's a yacht.
Some cops assume because you've
been persecuted falsely all over...
Persecuted falsely?
I'm sure the lieutenant didn't mean
to offend you, Miss Conley.
Excuse me, please.
- Watch how you're kicking my shins.
- Vince, give me a hand.
I thought perhaps you could use
a drink.
Yeah, like some dumb cops
could use some manners.
That much over the flagstones,
Mr. Hallett.
When are you gonna quit asking her
and start telling her for a change?
Would you like to step out
while I'm doing this?
You gonna do it this way? Yeah.
Thanks.
There you are.
- You're not joining?
- No.
I guess where you've been,
you can lap it up all you want.
Well, here's to the boys
in the friendly trenches.
Skol.
It's a wonderfully strong vintage.
I don't know what you're after
with me, Mr. Hallett...
...but I will say I like the way
you're going after it.
But I think it's only fair to warn you...
...l've been approached
from every angle...
...including this one of "let's get
her loaded and see what happens."
I don't doubt it.
Due to some kind of chemicals
in my makeup, I guess...
...they always run out of money before
they ever find out what happens.
Well, thank you for telling me.
Now, to get back to this yachting trip
that you took with Pete.
Wasn't this boat owned
by Mr. Ben Costain?
- It was owned by somebody.
- Yes, of course.
It was a big boat.
I can't imagine it being unowned.
But Costain owned it, and you were
on it when it went to the West Indies.
Since when is trips
on yachts illegal?
I told you, we're not accusing you
of anything.
It's Ben Costain we're after.
How many guys have already gone
after that person...
...and ended up 12 feet under?
I think the government has
a way to finally get him...
...if we can get some help from you.
Me?
He didn't notice if I had three heads
or four that whole delightful cruise.
Now, on this trip
to the West Indies...
...the boat put in
to several islands, didn't it?
- Did it?
- You know it did. Why?
I don't know. I took it Mr. Costain
was interested...
...in some untamed natives perhaps.
And at one of these islands,
this man came aboard the yacht.
Signor Maracelli.
The Italian garden expert. He taught
me to say his name himself.
Did you notice how long
he stayed aboard?
Sure. Until we let him off one night,
near Florida someplace.
For what reason?
Oh, he was looking
for some night-blooming wildlife.
Did he come back to the yacht?
They told us the signor
was destroyed in the swamp.
These are people that you
don't doubt their word.
When they say somebody's
in the swamp...
...you don't ask for wet shoes.
Yes.
Well, Signor Maracelli's real name
happens to be Frank Domano...
...one of the bosses of the Mafia.
- I thought he'd get someplace.
He's been involved in quite a few
murders since he was destroyed.
And by smuggling a man
of this kind into the country...
...Costain perjured his application
for citizenship.
I mean that when Costain swore he
was a man of good moral character...
...he lied.
And the testimony of either you
or Pete could prove that he lied.
Well, unless Pete has changed
an awful lot from the good old days...
...I don't get a very clear picture
of him busting his back...
...to call a man like Mr. Costain
a liar.
How about you?
When I think of it in connection
with myself...
...I just don't get no picture at all,
clear or otherwise.
Why not? Afraid?
Coward would describe it better,
Mr. Hallett.
Don't you think
we could protect you?
I wouldn't wanna put you
to the test...
...knowing how embarrassed
you'd be if you flunked.
And why did you drag me up here
when Pete could tell you?
Or has he already been approached...
...and did he spot the drawbacks
as fast as I did?
Pete's dead.
I'm assuming it wasn't old age.
He was murdered
by the Costain mob.
I wouldn't wanna say I told you so,
but that's a point I'd make.
It was a ruthless, vicious,
unnecessary killing...
...like all the others Costain has been
responsible for the last 25 years.
He's been at it long enough
to get good.
You don't seem to understand.
We're trying to deport Costain.
It should be everyone's responsibility
to see that we're successful.
- That's the way you feel.
- Yes, I do.
If anyone has any help
to give us...
...it's his obligation to give it.
If anybody got anything
but a kick in the face from society...
...I don't doubt he might owe
something back to it.
You realize you're the only one
who can help us.
I'm afraid I've been wasting
your time, Mr. Hallett.
Wasting?
The more I think,
the more I realize...
...it was the North Indies
we went to on our trip.
It was the West Indies.
"Good evening. Have you called for
one of our tastefully gay dinners?" No.
Hello? I'd like to speak to somebody
about your lobster thermidors.
For eating, yes.
- You can order anything.
- That's nice to hear.
Only after we've finished
our talk about Costain.
You mean the subject's
not exhausted?
I wish you wouldn't make up
your mind...
...until you carefully thought it over.
My mind was making up
while I was hearing...
...that Pete was no longer with us.
I'm not denying that it is dangerous.
But I can assure you nothing
is going to be left undone...
...to give you
every possible protection.
Yeah, but how can I even think
about it...
...when I'm famished
all over the place?
Perhaps you're not acquainted with
what my rights as a prisoner are...
...under several
already-legislated laws.
Section 3, article 12:
Feeding of prisoners.
Prisoners will be fed at three regulated
intervals during the daylight hours.
At 6 in the mornings, at 12:00 noons
and at 5 p.m.
Today, these intervals have been
anything but regulated.
Do you want to check my authenticity
in the book of regulations, Mr. Hallett?
Miss Conley, I bow
to your authenticity.
After this we'll try
and stick to the rules.
Yeah, you do that.
It's me again, about
those lobster thermidors.
- Would you like me to order for you?
- I'd like the fun of doing it.
All right. But before I leave,
I'd like to assure you...
...no one is going to make you
do anything against your will.
I'm afraid there isn't much
of a chance of that happening.
I'll be back later.
Good. No, I don't wanna talk
to the manager.
I wanna talk to the man that cooks
those tastefully gay dinners.
You may as well stuff yourself too.
Tonight it's on the taxpayers.
How'd it go?
I didn't expect much on the first try.
She didn't jump at the chance, huh?
Well, what's the plan now?
I'll talk to the governor about
making a deal on her sentence...
...and get a couple of other things
going.
How long can we keep it
from Costain if we've got her here?
I'm sorry to say, he's got connections
in prison like anywhere else.
He knows we picked her up and
haven't arrived at the jail with her...
...so he'll figure
we've got her stashed.
Well, in the meantime,
please be nice to her.
It won't hurt our cause a bit
if you treat her like a lady.
- Will she know what we're doing?
- There wouldn't be a lady left...
...if every time one of them acted
ladylike, she got kicked in the face.
Now, take good care of her.
She's no good to us
if she won't testify.
Yeah, if she's too dead.
Yeah.
- Where's Conley?
- She wanted to take a shower.
- Shower?
- I didn't see any harm in it!
So this is what the police
has sunk to.
The next time she takes a shower,
you sit on her lap. I mean it.
You ever lay a fat hand
on my person again...
...and the prison board will hear
about it before I'm even dry!
I won't lose him again.
Dumb slob.
Losing that DA. I don't know where
he's been the last two hours.
We'll find out where they've taken her.
There's no need to get so upset.
We'll find out, eh?
For 200-grand-a-year attorney's fees,
you couldn't even find out...
...they were gonna spring
Tonelli on us.
I don't have all your sources
of information, Ben.
Yeah.
- Well?
- Nothing yet.
The money I spend to get people
in all the places where it counts...
...they can't even find out where
they're hiding one lousy dame.
They leave prison to take her
to city jail three hours ago.
They haven't got there yet.
Tonelli, they thought they had
hidden out at Staten Island.
Where do they think this one
will be safe?
I wouldn't worry too much about it,
in any case, Ben.
Wouldn't you?
They're not trying to run you out
of your own country...
...and send you to some lousy place
you don't even remember.
She isn't going to hurt us, Ben.
No, she isn't.
Just let me find out
where they're keeping her...
She's in Room 2409,
St. Charles Hotel.
Girl's in Room 2409
at the St. Charles Hotel.
Room 2409, St. Charles Hotel.
Have you ever stopped to consider
what you'd look like completely bald?
- What?
- My sponsor's product...
... means exactly what it says.
Yes, folks, this is your old hillbilly
cousin, Mississippi Mac.
If up until now you haven't had
any hillbilly cousins in your home...
... open up your hearts,
and I'm gonna creep right in.
Oh, brother.
We've only been on the air
six hours and 47 minutes...
... but we'll be on until Monday
and longer than that...
... if it takes it to raise that $50,000.
Leave it on!
If you folks out there have been
saying to yourself:
"What will I do with that $ 100
that's been laying around...
... and collecting dust
and curious glances?"
Send it in to old Mississippi Mac...
... and some boy will get a chance...
... to lead a normal, bronco-busting,
rope-twirling life. Yes, sir.
While you're sending in
your donations, I'll sing for you.
He is pretty awful.
Perhaps we better just turn him off
for now...
...because he's gonna be on all night
anyway.
Never mind, peeping John.
I made sure there was nothing
left over for you to enjoy.
Bad as it is in prison to have to share
your shower with the inmates...
...at least we don't have
to be slapped by the police.
You've hauled men in for less.
Willoughby, you got a needle
and thread?
- What do you want it for?
- This is strangling my circulation off.
Maybe there's a seam
we can open up...
...so I won't be so scrunched
and pinched in places.
- I could go down to the drugstore.
- You can call.
- I'd like a little coffee too.
- They'll send that up too.
Afraid I won't come back,
lieutenant?
All right, go ahead.
Besides, when a person's places
are scrunched and pinched...
...something's liable
to bust right out.
That'd drive all the peeping Johns
in the place stark staring crazy.
- Will you shut up about my...
- I won't be long, lieutenant.
- Oh, my pocketbook.
- Charge it to the room.
Is that the way a genuine model
does it?
Again, please?
You used to be a model, didn't you?
How could you tell?
It's on your police record.
You models must lead a gay life
for yourselves, huh?
Never have to worry about who's
gonna pick up the dinner tab.
It's not a gay life?
What's gay about blistered feet and
a bunch of sleazy married guys...
...with ideas that were stale
when the Romans was eating lions?
How long were you at it?
Modeling?
Since I was 16.
Sixteen?
Well, what should I have done,
sold pencils maybe?
Or gone on relief, for which there
isn't any for 16-year-old girls?
- What did you do, lie about your age?
- Who to?
They're more interested
you're a real build kid...
...not how old a real build kid.
- Yeah.
Who got you the job?
I was waiting for a bus
one windy day...
...when all the skirts was blowing.
This fella drives up in a convertible
and struck up an introduction.
He was a real cornball. And he
sort of looked me over, and he said:
"Well, now, are there any more
at home like you, little lady?"
I told him the only thing
there was more of...
...was a brother 6-foot-4, who liked
to knock out teeth for exercise.
Why, I just made this brother up
out of my head for protection.
So then what happened?
And, well, he went on and said:
"A little girl like you shouldn't
be waiting all alone...
...for buses in this big, cold world.
I'll introduce you to a friend of mine
that makes bathing suits."
So I told him I didn't know anything
about how to make bathing suits.
And he said, "No, little lady,
you wouldn't make them.
You'd wear them."
He explained that he didn't mean
at beaches...
...but at buyers' shows, where these
out-of-town fellas like himself...
...would come to pick up
whatever looked good to them.
And whatever looks good to
these fellas is that old combination...
...of "most girl, least bathing suit,"
if you know what I mean.
Yeah, I think I do.
So I got the bathing-suit job.
And then...
...for a year there, we were sort of
making plans for getting married...
...until one gloomy day, this older
woman pops up from Omaha...
...and she cries and wrings
her hands and pleads with me...
...that I should leave him alone,
for his own good.
I should leave him alone,
Men.
They ought to trade themselves in
for something a girl really needs.
Well, you've got it all figured out
about men, haven't you?
You're all alike.
You only got different faces
so we girls can tell you apart.
- Take yourself, for instance.
- What about me?
I walk out here with no skirt...
...and your eyes bang out like you just
found some long lost gold mine.
Oh, sure. Everybody's after you,
every minute.
- It might seem so, if you were me.
- Well, you can relax, honey.
Thanks, I intend to.
I could come back from 10 years
alone on the moon, half-crazy...
...and watch you swimming, stripped,
at the Y for hours and walk out...
...with no thoughts in my head except
where I could get myself a good meal.
Now, that was
a crummy thing to say.
It wasn't as bad as all that.
Since I was the one that was insulted,
I'll be the judge of how bad it was.
Okay, I'm sorry.
If you didn't know where I was from,
you wouldn't talk to me like that.
Now, look, I said I was sorry.
And I mean it.
I'm sorry.
Well, it doesn't matter
much anyway...
...since none of us swim stripped at
the Y, even when people are watching.
And how could you know that all you'd
be thinking about was a good meal?
You might not be as interested
in food as you think you'd be.
Vince? Vince?
- Trouble on the roof.
- Lee, get in there and stay with her!
Hurry up, Willoughby!
- What did I do?
- We found him hiding in the elevator.
I work there.
That's my job.
Maybe that's true, maybe not.
He was acting funny.
See how you act if about
20 guys jump on you.
Take him and check with the manager.
If you make a mistake, apologize.
Packer, check the elevator shafts.
Seal them off at the roof.
- You mean, climb inside them?
- You heard me.
- You heard him.
- Yes, sir.
- Glad you're a lieutenant these days?
- Any day.
Lee?
What was the matter?
Oh, just an elevator man.
He kind of got off course.
I was just thinking, why should I have
them steamed clams for dinner?
You've gone from lobster thermidor
to pheasant to steamed clams.
- Now you wanna change again?
- So?
Any reason, except trying
to bankrupt the government?
When does a woman need a
reason for changing her mind?
- Mr. Hallett said I could have anything.
- He didn't know what he was saying.
With all this changing,
how do you expect to get fed?
Well, it's just that I want it right
when I do eat.
They're gonna love you in the kitchen.
Anyway, I'm canceling the clams out.
Fine.
When I think how it was with you cops
the last time I was framed...
I was hauled in all over, and when
I asked for some water...
...or legal advice, what did you say?
"Drop 10,000 feet dead."
Look, I never saw you before tonight.
Unfortunately, a cop is a cop.
You were sent up on accessory
to a crime and harboring a criminal.
And being a cop, you couldn't
imagine it might be a phony rap?
I never met one of you girls
who wasn't up on a phony rap.
Why should a cop strain his brain to
give anybody the benefit of his doubt?
All right.
What was this crime?
The one you weren't
an accessory to?
Well, this payroll, where I was working
as a model, was stuck up.
All by itself?
Or did your boyfriend help?
So what? How was I to know he was
gonna do a stupid thing like that?
- Didn't he do anything stupid before?
- All right, he might have.
Was he gonna have his record
tattooed on his forehead?
- Why didn't you ask for credentials?
- Now he tells me.
Let's see if I can give you
the rest of the facts, ma'am.
This guy romances you and finds out
all about the payroll setup.
When he finally pulls the job,
he bungles it and a guard gets shot...
...and the boyfriend himself probably
takes a bullet in a not-too-vital spot.
How does he do it
with nothing to go on?
- Except files that tell the whole story.
- I didn't need police files.
That story was old and stale when
they were sticking up pyramids.
So after he gets shot,
he comes running to you...
...and you hide him
in your apartment...
...the last place in the world the cops
would ever think of looking for him.
How does he figure it out
with nothing to go on?
Except a charge that reads
"harboring a criminal."
You did hide him.
So, what's so phony about the rap?
How was I to know he was gonna
stick up the joint?
- Then you were a chump to hide him.
- A chump, I was.
But that isn't what I was charged with.
You don't believe me, do you?
Well, a jury didn't, that's obvious.
What jury?
This $ 75 lawyer I hired told me
to plead guilty...
...and throw myself on
the mercy of this judge.
The only mercy was he didn't
hang me on the spot.
After serving four years
of this guy's mercy...
...next time, I'm gonna put some
poison in the hollow of my tooth.
The whole point of this is, I've decided
I don't want any steamed clams.
Okay.
What have you decided
you want now?
Well, I was sort of thinking maybe
I'd have something under glass.
Like cracked crab or...
...crepes of chicken.
Well, there's such a thing.
You want to order some of it for me?
Please?
I'd be two days getting up the nerve.
You better do it yourself.
If somebody should locate him,
have him call me.
My office here will know
where to reach me all night.
Yeah.
Thanks.
All I've dug up is she's got a father
and a married sister in the city.
Those are probably old addresses,
but we'll get on them in the morning.
Tonight.
- Tonight?
- Tonight.
Do you realize that that trial reopens
in exactly 37 hours?
Without Conley as a witness,
we'll be sent back to law school.
Okay. Any news from the governor?
No, he's off someplace opening
an apple festival or something.
He'll get back to me
tonight sometime.
If he agrees to commute the rest of her
sentence, do you think she'll testify?
All we can do is try it on her for size.
- Yes?
- Mr. Rickles to see you.
- Who?
- Rickles, Marvin Rickles.
He says he's the attorney
for Mr. Costain.
- Send him in.
- I'll go.
He probably doesn't like witnesses
when he bribes government officials.
Don't you want to hear
what he has to say?
I get sick so easily.
I apologize for disturbing you
at this late hour, Mr. Hallett.
What difference does time make
if you have something to say?
- Sit down.
- I'll only keep you a moment.
We've heard rumors, about another
secret witness, that have disturbed us.
I don't know what you heard.
You have a secret witness you're
going to spring in court Monday.
My experience a few days ago taught
me that I can't surprise you people.
- I don't know what you mean.
- I mean you were ready for Tonelli.
Are you accusing Costain of having
anything to do with Tonelli's death?
Oh, knock it off, Rickles.
This office isn't wired for anything,
so don't play persecuted client.
Tonelli was a cheap hoodlum
with hundreds of enemies.
Anyone could have killed him.
Yes, and the stork could have
brought him first.
I don't believe that anymore...
...because I know, even with
police as good as ours...
...you can always dig up
one or two who'll sell out.
And you did dig them up, didn't you?
- They tipped you off about Tonelli.
- You'll have to back up those charges.
Oh, that's all.
In a hearing of this kind...
...the defense has a right to question
all witnesses beforehand.
I didn't say I had a witness, you did.
And don't think I'm going to sit still for
any of your unethical trial practices.
I've been conditioned to stomach
almost anything.
But not hearing someone like
you talk about ethics.
I'm not gonna take this...
Ethics! Don't you choke
when you say that word?
- We have certain legal rights...
- You don't have any rights to anything!
Except to be stamped out
like any other disease.
- We'll see when I get you in court.
- We'll see. Get out of here.
If it's the last thing I ever do...
It's gonna be the last thing you ever
did if you don't get out of here!
Can I bust in for a minute?
Thirty seconds.
I thought reporters were supposed to
be drunk this time on Saturday night.
Just the ones with money.
What was Rickles doing here?
- Trying to buy you off?
- He thinks I'm unethical.
You know something? I am.
Whenever I deal with something dirty,
I always get a little soiled myself.
I think the whole thing's
a joke anyway.
Costain's a public menace who's been
murdering and looting for 25 years.
What's he finally brought to trial on?
Denaturalization charges.
Well, it's a start.
Now, look, Jim...
...if I can get one witness on
that stand to testify against him...
...then all of the others who know
anything against Costain...
...will suddenly get courage.
Then we'll start hitting him
with something that counts.
But first, I need that one witness.
Have you got one?
Your 30 seconds are up.
You might as well not show up
in court, Lloyd...
...if you don't have
something spectacular.
Well?
Will you be in court Monday?
I'll be the one with the briefcase.
You can only hope he taps
a hole through his head.
Aren't you afraid that stuff's gonna
spoil you for real police work?
The real thing is for 6-year-olds.
And the girls in these,
don't they ever get cold?
- Not those girls.
- Want to borrow it?
Anything sexier than
Popular Mechanics...
...I break out in a rash, all over.
You enjoy your dinner?
I finished it.
You didn't think I would?
I didn't think anybody could.
What do you say we drink a toast?
Oh, come on, lieutenant.
You have no idea how long it's been
since I had a toast with any man...
...much less something like you.
No kidding. You have no idea how
utterly desirable you are to a girl.
What's the toast?
Here's to the men
that blow up prisons.
Don't worry, I won't snitch on you
that you drank on duty.
Just make sure you don't tell
what he drank to.
I'll take it inside.
You know, he's sort of nice.
Is he married?
I never saw him before.
What's there about him
that you like?
I don't know.
That he's here, I guess.
Have you decided what
you're going to do?
- About the lieutenant?
- No.
I mean about Mr. Hallett.
Why? Has he tried to get
you to work on me too?
You know better than that.
I'm sorry.
Hallett tells me I owe it to society to
testify at the trial, as my last living act.
What do you think I owe
to society, Willoughby?
I wouldn't want to say.
If I was your daughter,
what would you tell me to do?
I never tell her what to do.
But I have tried to teach her
to face her obligations.
Well, who says
this is my obligation?
And who wants a hero with her insides
blasted out with a shotgun?
And how are you gonna be sure
your daughter doesn't end up like me?
There isn't any way I can be sure.
But I can make her feel wanted...
...and see to it that she gets
all the love I have to give.
Those are the things all of you girls
seem to need the most.
That's a fact.
All the love I ever got,
you could put in your right eye.
Yeah, you're right.
A little love never hurt anybody.
Yeah.
Anything else?
Yeah, tell her about
the governor's offer.
Give her a chance to think it over
before I get there.
I'm leaving right now.
Why don't you try and get some rest.
Hours are gonna get 80 minutes long
at 4:00 in the morning.
You're right.
Wake me if you turn that thing on and
Mississippi Mac suddenly gets funny.
I just talked to Hallett.
- He's such a refined man.
- Yeah.
He says he's gonna be able to
knock off the rest of your sentence...
...if you string along with him
Monday morning.
- The whole 11 months?
- Yep.
Have you any idea how long 11
months is in a place like that?
Long. Very, very long.
Then that's quite an offer.
Maybe.
How come you haven't asked me
for a date tonight?
Oh, maybe I figured it was Saturday
night and you're all tied up.
Or maybe you just don't like girls.
No, I never found anything
I liked better.
For a couple of reasons, one of them
being how much it costs to feed you...
I just can't figure you
for Pete Tonelli's girl.
I told you, I wasn't.
But the boat trips all over the Western
Hemisphere, how about that?
My actions were as pure
as the driving snow.
And what's more,
Pete was the brother of Mitzi Tonelli...
...who was one of my closest friends
during a certain period of my life.
That's why you went yachting,
because Mitzi asked you to?
No, because he asked me to.
That's what I mean. Why?
Did he have money then or what?
He didn't have nothing then.
He was just a poor, ugly,
miserable, little beat-up guy.
But you saw something in him that...
What was there to see? He had
nothing nobody could want. Nothing.
That's why when Costain invited him
to bring a girlfriend, he was in a spot.
- Who'd go with him?
- You.
Sure. I felt sorry for him.
He wanted to look good, so he thought
if he took along a kind of...
...pretty girl...
- Yeah, a pretty girl?
Well, anyway, he thought I was pretty.
And he figured if he had a girl...
...of this type along to hold hands
with him while this person watched...
- Well, that makes sense.
- It didn't neither.
They never looked our way once
during the whole voyage.
But you were ready, weren't you?
To hold hands, nothing more.
Only hands.
I get the picture.
I guess you think it was
kind of cheap of me, huh?
No.
That sounds to me like
the kind of a favor...
...that only a real nice girl
would think of doing.
You really think that?
Yep.
Well, it was nothing, really.
Anyway, Mitzi Tonelli was your
best friend at this period.
She could strangle and never
get a tear from me now.
Thank you very much there, boys.
Hey, folks, now we've got to do
a lot better than that...
Television should be so good
that when you close your eyes...
...it sounds like a radio.
I'd like some real soft music.
Turn that... That thing on the left
till it points to R.
- Why are you a cop?
- Why not?
Aren't there other jobs that are better?
Better for what?
Some people like some things,
some others like other things.
I got out of the Army,
it was the best job I could get. I like it.
You like going around
arresting people all the time?
Well, there's always the parades.
Come on, lieutenant.
I'll keep you on your toes,
where a good cop's supposed to be.
I guess you're not supposed to be
dancing with your prisoners.
Are you?
I'm just trying to remember if
the question ever came up before.
I guess the reason you're
holding back is...
...your wife wouldn't like you to
dance with a girl on duty.
Even off duty.
If I had a wife.
You don't?
Last time I looked, I sure didn't.
Vince!
Vince! Vince!
Room below this one!
- Get the house doctor.
- Right.
Get some more men up here.
- Oh, Vince.
- Operator? Get a doctor up here.
- It hurts.
- Then get me police headquarters.
Yeah.
Let's get her in the bedroom.
Now, hold it a minute.
Nobody's going in there.
What's happened?
There's been a shooting
somewhere in the top stories, sir.
- Who is he?
- No identification yet.
It wasn't the fall that killed him.
He was shot before he started down.
All he needs now is a well-dug grave.
You're hurting me!
- How is she?
- She's got a crease through...
- I wanna talk to you!
- You'd better lie down.
Enough of this lying down.
I wanna go to my nice, safe prison.
You have to lie down
and let the shot work.
There are too many shots already
working around here.
You're better off here
than anyplace else.
- Lf you're not dying, you're doing fine.
- We're all doing our best.
- Somebody isn't!
- I'll give orders that...
- What's the matter with Willoughby?
- Doc!
Ambulance! She should've
been taken care of first!
She didn't say anything. I guess she
was waiting till you finished with her.
It wasn't too much of a trick
to get up there from that.
- Fine, thanks.
- It was an awful thing to have happen.
On your honeymoon.
I thought it was the waiter
with the champagne.
When I answered, they pushed past
me and one covered me with a gun.
- How many of them?
- There were three.
And they were just terrible to me.
I'd have torn them to pieces
if it wasn't for that gun.
Yeah, lucky for them
they thought to bring it along.
They were wearing some overalls
and carrying those short planks.
- Everything's under control.
- Come upstairs when you're through.
Is that blood?
I took two bullets through the chest.
Just routine.
It was actually three bullets.
We haven't told him yet.
All right, let's hurry up with this.
There were four of them, not three.
The fourth had a gun on the elevator
operator to keep the elevator ready.
When the deal went sour,
they ran in the elevator...
...and dropped to the alley,
where they had a car.
I just clocked it.
They were out in 40 seconds.
Nice to know how
they do these things.
You still want to move her
to the city jail?
Oh, you mean, now?
Now that Costain knows we got her
and Willoughby's shot to pieces?
Not before, when she should
have been there, is that it?
I've got my side of the job on this,
to see she gets on that stand.
- Dead or alive?
- Alive, and that's your job.
- That's what I'm trying to do!
- Do you want to take her?
Costain has probably got
this hotel covered...
...just waiting for us to pull
something stupid like that.
Well, then I guess we better not.
All this hasn't accomplished
very much, has it?
You couldn't get her on that stand now
with a gun in her back.
Then why don't we just quit.
Wave a white flag out the window and
maybe Costain will be nice enough...
...and not make us leave the country.
Hi.
How you feel?
Terrible.
I feel groggy all over.
Something funny has been going on.
I couldn't get that dopey from
the dinner I ate last night.
I'm not gonna drink or eat
anything until I know what's in it.
You couldn't live two hours
without eating. Here.
Watch. If we're gonna go,
we'll go together.
See?
Drink it up.
It'll make you feel better.
When's that gonna be?
How's the arm?
Feels like somebody's been
gnawing on it with dull teeth.
- Want the doctor?
- Only the one at the prison.
I've never been appreciative enough of
how free from killers those places are.
How's Willoughby?
Just the same, no change.
Hey!
I got a surprise for you.
There.
Well, go on, open it.
What's in it?
It's sitting right in your lap.
Why don't you find out.
White with polka dots!
Hey, you better look at it
sitting down, huh?
No, I'm all right now.
Good as the Easter parade, 1902?
Better.
Hey, wait a minute.
Could there be sentiments behind this
not kosher enough to write on a card?
- What?
- Government officials bribing people?
- I thought it was the other way around.
- What are you talking about?
Mr. Hallett thinks that polka dots will
make me forget that visitor last night?
Oh, no wonder taxes keep going up.
Nobody uses their brains anymore,
only their expense accounts.
Somebody's gonna get investigated.
Well, did I stumble onto the motive?
If you say so, sister, all right.
So it's "sister" again, is it?
Yeah.
I don't care how bad the motive is,
I won't let it upset my enjoyment.
So, purely out of curiosity about the fit,
I'm gonna try it on.
So you can tell Mr. Hallett
quite clearly...
...that my acceptance of this
gift doesn't mean I intend...
...to get caught dead
on his witness stand.
The intervals are getting
irregulated again.
Somebody better spring
for my breakfast.
- Well?
- For the fifth time, it looks great.
I thought so too,
but I wanted another opinion.
Your breakfast is out there.
You're not gonna eat?
Lmagine me having to be told that.
But I'm so excited,
I couldn't eat a drop.
- Good morning.
Good morning.
Well, look at you.
Yeah, I got it on me.
Turn around, let's see you.
That looks like about $200 worth
of dress.
And a million dollars' worth of model.
Where'd you get it?
- What?
- Where'd it come from?
I thought you and the government...
Like those grafters with
their expense accounts.
You and that dress were certainly
made for each other.
It's the nicest dress I ever owned.
More polka dots, for one thing.
I'm sorry.
I really mean it, I'm sorry.
- Where'd you get it?
- Get it?
Oh, it wasn't any trouble, really.
I called up a guy I know in Jersey...
...got him out of bed at
4:00 in the morning...
...he drove in, opened his shop,
took him a couple hours.
Wasn't any trouble, really.
- Vince...
- You like it?
Like it?
He gave it to me.
Well, that's nice.
I wish I could wear it
to church this morning.
You religious, Sherry?
Doesn't look very much like it, does it?
They tried to get me
to go to church in prison.
What kind of place is that to go?
Can I have a cigarette?
Well, there was a time
when I was a kid...
...that I used to go to church
every Sunday.
I hope you understood
I meant what I said last night...
...about going back to prison.
Miss Conley, believe...
- I'm not fooled by this lull in the killing.
- But if Costain...
Mr. Costain and I are both
interested in one law:
The law of self-preservation.
You've heard of it. It's on the books.
Yes, I've heard of it.
I know what I'm asking is dangerous.
Take it from the target,
it's very dangerous.
I know. But until we get rid
of Costain for good...
...someone's always at risk.
Since that life happens to be mine,
you'll excuse me if I turn and run.
Until somebody finally
has the courage...
If somebody doesn't start
getting me back to my cell...
...l'm gonna scream for lawyers.
- No!
Wait another hour, just an hour.
It'll take that long
to arrange the move anyway.
Please.
All right.
One hour.
But after, I'm gonna stick my head
out that window...
...and start screaming
for some advice of counsel.
What happens in an hour?
We've located her older sister.
One of my men
is on his way with her now.
- And what can she do?
- That's what I'm trying to find out.
Can't keep her much longer
if she keeps screaming to go back.
Why not?
She's a prisoner, isn't she?
Prisoners have some rights, Vince.
She wasn't sentenced to battle
the whole Costain mob.
Good lawyer could beat my brains
for keeping her here against her will.
Look, do you mind if I duck home,
get myself a clean shirt?
- Who's on duty?
- Fred Packer.
- He can take care of anything.
- All right, but don't stay away too long.
Get in.
Your sister doesn't know
that you're coming.
Yeah, that's what you said.
Packer.
- Make yourself at home.
- You want me to clear out?
Thanks, Fred.
- Shall I get her, Mr. Hallett?
- Yes.
Won't you sit down, please?
Would you care for a...?
Well, I had no idea criminals
were treated like this.
It isn't always like that.
Maybe Sherry's been right
and I was wrong.
Maybe it doesn't pay to be an honest,
hardworking woman...
...who never gets
into any kind of trouble.
She doesn't really mean that,
Mr. Hallett.
She never believes she was wrong
about anything in her whole life.
Hardworking Clara,
give you the shirt off her back...
...if you pay her twice its worth.
- How are you, Sherry?
Do you really care?
Or is that all you could think of to say?
- It's been a long time, so...
- Yeah. How long has it been, Clara?
- Six years? Eight? Elev...?
- I was laid up for quite a while.
Bust all your fingers, so you couldn't
write a letter or a postcard?
Or maybe you didn't know
I was in prison.
- Yeah, Roy heard about it somewhere.
- How is good old Roy?
- Still kicking kids for exercise?
- I better leave you two alone.
No, stick around.
Because I want you to see...
...what a dumb move this was
on your part. What was the plan?
That my loving sister was gonna
talk me into going into that court?
There really wasn't any plan.
I merely thought...
Well, you goofed, Mr. Hallett.
You'd have had to dug real deep...
...to find anybody that had less
of a chance with me.
Even if she could've talked me
into anything, think she would...
...unless there's something for her?
- That's not true.
Why isn't it?
You mean you've changed, Clara?
These days you'd bust both
your arms to help somebody...
...who was in trouble? And if
somebody needed a place to stay...
...you'd throw open all your doors?
It isn't my fault!
Roy didn't want you to stay!
- I asked you!
- He's my husband!
- It was his house!
- I knew it wasn't mine...
...the way I was shoved out!
That's the kind of sister to have.
She lets you know...
...not a soul cares if you live or die.
- And what was I supposed to do?
If I'd insisted you stay,
he'd have thrown me out with you!
You wouldn't wanna chance losing
such a wonderful guy as that?
You bet I wouldn't! Things hadn't been
any easier for me than for you.
If you think I wanted to lose the only
home I'd ever had, you were crazy!
I was crazy, all right!
Because somewhere I'd heard...
...that sisters mean something
to each other.
But you knocked that idea
out of my head...
...before it felt at home there.
- We all had to look out for ourselves.
Maybe it never occurred to you...
...that if I'd had anything that even
looked like a home when I was 16...
...that maybe I wouldn't have
ended up in prison.
Yeah. Maybe I could have
amounted to something...
...if I'd had even a little help then.
- Put yourself in my place.
- With that guy?
- He's been good to me!
- What's he done for you?
Except let you carry out
the garbage when it rains.
He gave me a home
and some security.
And you ought to know what that
meant after years of living...
...with Mom and Pop fighting.
- I just ran out of sympathy.
Oh, what difference does it make?
It's a real laugh that you thought
she could talk me into anything.
Oh, I didn't come up here
to talk you into testifying.
I came up here to beg you not to.
Why?
Why do you care what I do?
I don't. I mean, I know I don't have any
right to interfere, but Roy wanted me...
Are you trying to tell me
that old nasty-heart cares...
...whether I stick my neck out or not?
- It isn't that.
You see, we own a small barroom
of our own now.
Roy thinks
if you go against Costain...
...he'll take it out on anybody
who's connected with you in any way.
Did you hear that?
I shouldn't testify
against Costain...
...because it might be bad
for Roy's business!
- Yeah. Well, it might be.
- Oh, no!
You don't know how it is
in bar business...
...with all those licenses they can
take away at any time.
All Costain would have to do is pick up
a phone and ruin anybody he wants.
- And you've got the nerve to ask me...
- Makes no difference to you...
...and it does to us.
- Lf I could take a kick...
...at that miserable husband of yours
by getting up on that stand, I'd...
- Get out of here!
- Please!
Of all the lousy...
Get out of here!
Oh, Mrs. Moran.
You brought me up here to let me
be insulted by some cheap dame...
...even if she is my sister?
- Lf you don't get out of here...
...you'll find I got a sister
with no hair and no teeth!
Roy was right!
You're no good, like Pop...
...and you're not worth helping!
I'm sorry, Miss Conley.
Why do we always have to act
like this? Like wild dogs...
...instead of blood sisters?
- But it wasn't altogether your fault.
- No.
I went after her
the minute I came into this room.
It's always been like that. Every time
I even see her, I don't know...
...all those little hurts swell up in me.
- I could see that.
Did you see her? Like a scared rabbit,
afraid of everything.
Do you think she's ever shown any
sisterly responsibility to me? No.
Because it might be a threat
to her lousy little security.
- Yeah, I know.
- And what has it got her?
Solitary confinement with that
low character she's married to.
What a life. I'll bet if she admitted it,
she's miserable.
That's the thing I've been
trying to point out to you...
...about facing responsibilities.
- Yeah.
Oh, I get your point...
...but you've gotta be sure
that they are your responsibilities.
And provided...
...that what you gotta do doesn't take
all the nerve in the world...
...which you haven't got.
- You've got plenty, Sherry.
It takes courage.
And you gotta be born with it.
Or maybe I was born with it
and got it kicked out of me...
...by certain close members
of my immediate, crummy family.
Hold it, Arny.
He's mad at you
for killing his brother last night.
Doing everything your own way
these days, huh?
Why'd you shake the tail
on you yesterday?
Made it harder for me to find
out where you'd taken her.
Because I had
a smart matron in the car.
And that guy tailing me
was wearing a neon sign...
...to advertise he was following me.
And on top of this,
I guess you figured...
...you didn't have enough
front-page publicity lately.
Or did you just want to show
how good you can pop a gun?
It was your boy trying to get a medal.
He didn't care who he shot.
- He was after the girl.
- Then he read his instructions wrong.
Or did he figure you wanted two
for the price of one?
Next time, let's make it clear to him
who his friends are, huh?
Lots of things
will be different next time.
- Who's the woman they brought in?
- Her sister.
What do they want with her?
Hallett figures maybe
she can talk the girl into testifying.
- Can she?
- I don't know.
I left before they got there.
You want my opinion?
Nobody's gonna talk her
into nothing.
You got nothing to worry about.
Can you imagine how that relieves
me to hear him say I shouldn't worry?
That's what I pay him for,
to reassure me.
If anything goes wrong, he can
always say it was just an opinion.
Both ends against the middle, that's
the way Vince likes to play things.
- You asked me...
- I asked you to get rid of the girl...
...so she couldn't bother us.
- I told you, let's...
- He told me.
...see if she is gonna bother us.
Guess you forgot to tell me
he's running things now.
- I didn't mean it like that.
- Didn't you?
It would suit you just fine,
wouldn't it?
To see me booted
out of the country?
Wouldn't that be a sweet cover-up
for a cop on the take...
...the past 10 years?
To have his whole smelly past
put on a boat and sent someplace...
...where it couldn't ever
bother him again.
What do you want everybody's
neck sticking out for?
She's not gonna talk anyway.
Because I like everybody's
neck stuck out when mine is.
Know what's gonna happen
if she gets on that stand, don't you?
Look, she hasn't even come close
to saying she'll testify.
You haven't come close to saying
what you'll do if she does.
Mr. Costain wants to know
if he can depend on you.
- Do what? Shove her out the window?
- Lf that's what it has to be.
Sure, with Hallett and 20 cops
watching every minute.
And why should I,
when it isn't necessary?
Because as long as she's still
at the hotel, we can give you help.
After she's moved
to the city jail tonight...
...you'll have to do it all by yourself.
- Nobody's moving her to any city jail.
At 8:00 tonight, they are.
- How do you know?
- You know I make it a point...
...to know everything about everything
that concerns me.
So if you want any help, you'll have
to get it before they move her.
- There isn't any way it can be done.
- We'll show you.
I don't want you to miss a word.
Next time we meet,
it could be a big celebration...
...lots of money
being passed around...
...or it could be the last look
at your face...
...before they start
shoveling dirt on it.
You made your point.
Good.
You do exactly like we tell you,
you'll be completely in the clear.
You don't have to do more than
you've been doing the past 10 years.
You just have to turn your back
and not worry about what's going on.
Yeah.
- What do I do?
- Just unlock the bathroom window...
...a couple of minutes
before 8:00 tonight.
The time is important.
Right before 8:00 tonight,
you unlock the bathroom window.
That way, maybe you'll get to live
a couple of years more.
No, sir!
Not me, Mr. Hallett.
If you just gotta move somebody
back to the city jail, fine.
- But it's not gonna be me.
- Isn't my idea, I was ordered to do it.
I don't care
who ordered you to do it.
The streets below
crawling with killers...
...and you wanna eject me
from my showers and room service...
...for a small, iron room
with only bars for comfort?
No, Mr. Hallett.
And in case you weren't listening, no.
You're a prisoner.
And you'll do
exactly as you're told.
Only if what I'm told to do
is to go back to my nice, safe prison...
...where I spent so many years without
being shot at or wounded even once.
What difference could it make whether
you're moved there or city jail?
Because moving to the city jail
is closer to the witness stand...
...which is the last place in the world
I've decided I'm gonna be.
- So that's really it, isn't it?
- Yeah.
Doesn't make any difference
about city jail.
You've decided that, as far as you're
concerned, everybody can go hang.
- I've been keeping this a secret?
- You've been stalling...
...until you can take another shower
or chisel another $20 meal.
Look, who dragged who
from prison?
Is it my secret police that dragged
you from your safe prison...
...to live in front of live ammunition
for two days?
- What's all this supposed to mean?
- I want out of here!
But alive!
And I'm not gonna testify even if you
give me gold plates on silver platters!
- Hello.
- She has it in her power to get rid of...
...one of the biggest menaces,
but she simply won't do it.
Right, and I want that menace to start
hearing I'm not gonna do anything.
I want all the newspapers
to say I'm not gonna do anything!
So nothing matters to you
except your own hide?
- Take it easy.
- Take it easy nothing!
This is the kind of selfishness
that turns my stomach.
"Me, me, me!
What's gonna happen to me?"
She doesn't care if the world burns
as long as the flames don't touch her!
- Calm down.
- Don't stall...
...it doesn't take long
for a bullet to go through a brain!
Well...
...weren't you a help out there.
- Why didn't you pitch in and help?
- I think she's been pitched at enough.
- Oh, you do?
- Yes, I do.
Look, she almost
got killed last night.
You been slugging at her
with everything from fancy meals...
...to you telling her how low she is.
- Maybe I feel that way.
Maybe you haven't
got any right to.
It's her life, you know.
You've been working
as long as I have on this case.
And to all appearances, you felt just
as strongly as I about getting Costain.
What's happened
to change you all of a sudden?
Maybe I'm getting fed up with all
the shooting going on.
They killed Tonelli, shot Willoughby.
We've gotta take her to city jail.
You're just giving me more good
reasons to get Costain.
They might be reasons to us,
but that doesn't mean they are to her.
She's the one that's got to get up
on that witness stand.
Well, I'll shed a few tears.
How'd you happen to find out
about this move to the city jail?
What...? What do you mean?
I just finished talking to Sherry
a minute ago.
- She's the only one I said a word...
- Mr. Hallett, phone.
All right.
While you're sitting there phoning, you
can tell the newspapers the status.
All right.
There goes our last chance.
Vince.
I'm sorry.
Maybe you could have been
police chief...
...or a senator from someplace if I
had enough courage.
Don't worry about it.
Thanks.
What's the matter?
Willoughby died 20 minutes ago.
They thought
she was rallying, but...
Oh, no.
She must have been trying to drag
me out of the way when she got hit.
And she didn't even
say anything...
...until the doc was through
with me.
Me.
The kind of person you could lose
any day in the week...
...and it still wouldn't
make any difference.
And who's gonna
take care of her daughter?
Who does that crazy jerk
think he is anyway?
Killing off nice people
like Willoughby.
He better be careful,
because somebody just might...
...run him out of this country,
where he really belongs.
And I think I know
who that somebody's gonna be.
- Now, wait a minute...
- You just got yourself a witness.
Friends, because it's Sunday night
here and I'm still going strong...
... my enemies
have started a rumor...
... that I haven't been on the job every
minute, that I nap...
... during the news bulletins.
Now, you folks know me
better than that.
I just don't play that kind
of dirty mahjong.
Fred.
Really rotten news
about Willoughby.
- Yeah.
- How many more will we lose...
...in this move to the jail?
There's more guys coming.
Show them what you want them to do.
You wanna make a bet that she never
gets to the city jail alive?
I was only kidding, Vince.
Forget it.
Masters?
- Yeah?
- What's Conley doing now?
Changing her clothes
for the trip to the jail.
She says if there's shooting,
she doesn't wanna take a chance...
...with her new dress.
- Yeah?
- It's Vince. Can I come in?
Sure, I'm decent enough for you.
I was hoping I'd get a chance to see
you before D-day starts.
It's another let-out job.
Listen, how do you know Willoughby
wants you to get up on that stand?
Why shouldn't she want me
to get the guy who killed her?
She'd have been able to see
that all you'll do is get yourself killed.
I suppose that...
...in all the years
Mr. Costain has been a hotshot...
...there've been lots of people that
could've stopped him along the way.
But for some reason,
nobody ever did.
So now the buck has been passed
right on down...
- Yeah, but you didn't ask for it.
- But I got it.
- So, what am I gonna do?
- Who says it's up to you anyway?
Well, Mr. Hallett
keeps saying it all along.
And I guess right now
I'm saying it myself.
- What are you doing?
- Checking everything.
Even if we're gonna move me?
We've still got half an hour.
Sherry, don't do it.
Don't worry about me, Vince.
I know what I'm getting into.
No, you don't.
Well, let's say it's 10 times worse
than I think it is now.
I'd still go ahead with it
because for the first time in my life...
...l'm facing up to something.
I kind of like the feeling.
Anyway...
...the nicest thing
that ever happened to me is that...
...you care whether I live or die.
I don't expect you to feel this way
for the rest of your life...
...or even five days from now...
...but I would
just like to tell you that...
...I think it's nice
that you feel that way now.
Maybe this isn't exactly the time...
...but I just wanted to tell you.
Vince.
- I wish you wouldn't be sore at me.
- For what?
For feeling this way about you.
I wouldn't hold you to anything
after this is over.
I'm not sore.
But with this move to the city jail...
...maybe this will be our last chance
to say anything.
$ 10 if you'll sing
"The Girl From Cactus Valley."
Well, what are we
waiting on, fellas?
- Harris!
- Yes, sir? Sorry, sir.
Would you turn that down?
Timers are set
for as long as you need.
Portrait of a modern man at war
with the machine age.
- How is she?
- Leave her alone!
She's getting dressed.
Shouldn't that door be open?
Well, she's been screaming about not
getting privacy when she's dressing.
Well, I...
I thought she might like a hat
to go with that dress that you...
Well, there's that little shop
downstairs and...
I don't know why...
...but these things give women
some kind of strange courage.
- Pretty awful, isn't it?
- Terrible.
Yeah.
You've gotten to think quite a lot
of that third-class citizen.
Almost always turns out that way.
Make a snap judgment of someone,
break them way down...
...then you find them
acting out so well...
...wonder how you had nerve
to grade them in the first place.
I never thought I'd see you
acting coy about anything.
Will you stop it?
We're all on edge.
Maybe we'll all go away
someplace after the trial.
You've been getting jumpy.
Besides, you could be with her all the
time, see that nothing happens to her.
You wouldn't be worried if you were
taking care of her yourself.
Why don't you leave her alone!
What's the matter, Vince?
Nothing! Nothing's the matter
except you kept hammering at her!
Wouldn't let her make up her mind!
So when she gets killed...
Vince!
This bathroom window
was unlocked from the inside.
Vince, Vince, Vince.
I don't think he expected
to find you here this morning.
There were times when I didn't expect
to be here myself.
Scared?
No.
Just mad.
Will the government
call its next witness, please?
Miss Sherry Conley.
Here we go.
Undesirable alien.
Do you swear the evidence
you're to give...
...before this court
will be the truth, the whole truth...
...and nothing but the truth?
I do.
Your name, please.
Sherry Conley.
What is your present address?
Upstate Women's Prison.
Occupation?
At present...
...gangbuster.